Our first question is what is the
Sabbath, its origins and purpose. And
you can take it one at a time.
Yes.
The Sabbath
can be viewed as a principle and as a
day.
The Sabbath day originated in Eden.
The Sabbath principle has always
existed. Let me say that again. The
Sabbath day because the Bible says in
Genesis 1:5, "And the evening and the
morning were the first day." So, we have
days as units of time introduced when
God made the heaven the earth and the
heavens associated with our earth. But,
the principle of the Sabbath which is
the recognition of who God is and the
sense of dependence upon him,
that has always existed. And so, the
Sabbath day began in the Garden of Eden,
but the Sabbath principle has always
existed which is total dependence on
God, recognizing him as the source of
life and the one who maintains and
sustains. So, the origin of the day
is back to Eden, but the principle is
all the way back and we cannot date it.
That's the question the answer to
question one. The Sabbath is a day of
worship when you do no work according to
the fourth commandment. It is set aside
to contemplate creation, but even more
so the creator who of course is Jesus
Christ creating at the behest of the
Father. It is a day to honor God without
the distraction of work or secular
activities, to focus and concentrate on
God, to stop all that we do that is
required to make a living and to keep
our eyes on the person who really is the
source of our living. It's a day of rest
for the believers, for the unbelievers,
for the land. There's a Sabbath for the
land once every 50 years or once every 7
years. And there's also a rest from from
debt. So, the Sabbath has several
levels, agricultural, personal,
spiritual. At every level there's the
concept of rest, but we're dealing with
the weekly rest which is the Sabbath
day. Again, the day goes back to Eden,
but the principle goes way back, way
back
into eternity that we cannot even
imagine.
So, that's the answer to question one.